if you're looking for ways to increase
your self-discipline don't seek the
acceptance of others and hold yourself
worthy then this video is for you if
you're not holding yourself within
yourself that's worthy and what you
expect from the world is surely gonna
hurt you and it's the great key to
success it's called task completion are
you always at the mercy of other people
goodness gracious it must be a nightmare
what's up believe nation it's Evan my
one word is believe and I believe in you
I believe you have an amazing gift
inside you that I want to see explode
out into the world now I started to
believe life series to each week explore
a different topic in personal
development to help you learn something
new about yourself so let's live our
best believe life and learn today how to
boost your self esteem enjoy
kicking us off at number one is hold
yourself worthy with the Yonghwa Van
Zandt when we think we are unworthy it
means that for some reason we believe
that we have to prove we have a right to
our space on the planet in life as we
are being who we are and that means that
we will do all manner of wonderfulness
to prove we deserve to be here and
usually with some of the common things
are we over commit over give we over do
we over excuse we over compensate and we
stay in difficult desperate hurtful
harmful situations much longer than it
is wise or productive to do so worth
what it is that you expect from the
world in response to who you are it's
very different from value self value
means how you hold yourself within
yourself and what you expect as a result
now in order to get to the word if
you're not holding yourself within
yourself that's worthy and what you
expect from the world is surely gonna
hurt you so here's an assignment for you
for the next 40 days every morning you
are to write for these statements of I
am I am love I am beauty I am peace I am
joy I am power I am worth I am value I
am truth I am life I am well health
whatever it is I am and write it as a
noun not as a verb not I am loving or I
am lovable I am love I am power every
day for 40 days if you miss a day go
back and do it again I am it will
restore your worth next is number to
change your state with Tony Robbins if
you see someone who's depressed
without me telling you anything you
could tell me that what person has a
physiology to them a way of using their
body what's their posture like slumped
where's their head down are they
breathing full or shallow you know
shallow do they talk really loud and
fast or more quiet and more hesitant in
order for us to feel any emotion anger
frustration uncertainty excitement we
have to use our body a certain one
emotion comes from emotion so most of us
have habits of using our body our breath
our movement our facial muscles we have
80 different muscles interphase 8 0 80
for most people this is the largest area
of unemployment in the country if you
want to change your life and you want to
be more assertive get around more
assertive people and model them take on
their posture move it seems artificial
and go stand with your hands on your
hips standing straight up if you stand
that way for two minutes like Superman
Wonder Woman within two minutes the
testosterone in you male or female
increases an average of 20% and the
cortisol which is the stress hormone
that stresses you out drops 15% in two
minutes and all you're doing is standing
like this and you're one-third more
likely to take action be more assertive
do something you normally wouldn't do
moving on the number three is increase
your self-discipline with Brian Tracy a
third way to build your self-esteem is
through self-discipline we say that
self-esteem leads to self discipline and
self discipline increases your
self-esteem so that means setting
priorities on your work saying to
yourself what is the most important
thing I could do right now and then
disciplining yourself to do that now
here's the key and it's the great key to
success it's called task completion
whenever you start and complete a task
your self-esteem goes up you like and
respect yourself more you feel like a
winner because completing a task is like
crossing a finish line it gives you a
feeling of winning so if you start and
complete any task your self-esteem goes
up if you start and complete your most
important task your self-esteem goes it
goes up very high and you feel sometimes
exhilarated
your brain releases endorphins which are
called nature's happy drug they make you
happy and not only that they motivate
you to want to do more things and to do
them better and to do them sooner as
well
next up at number four is find your one
word with me find your one word and it's
not just timely because I actually have
a book about it but really because I
feel it's one of the most important
things that you can do it's
understanding what you staying for as a
human being because you will likely say
no to opportunities that could support
you but you're really just afraid or you
say yes to opportunities that don't
support you but you don't have the the
framework to make that right decision
when you understand what it is that you
stand for you start to raise your
standards of the people that you're
around of what you will and will not
accept anymore and it just really makes
a big impact on your own self-confidence
when you are saying no to something it's
not out of fear it's out of principle
and being able to understand the
difference a lot of times when people
identify what their one word is it's
happy because they have clarity but also
sad because they realize how much of
things in their life are not congruent
with where they should be for you to
realize the potential that you have you
need to act a certain way that is most
true to you and you'll notice how many
things in your life currently the people
you're around to the businesses you're
involved in to the things that you're
doing on a day to day basis are not in
line with you achieving that best
version of yourself status and when you
realize what your one word is things
start to change
and so that self-awareness to understand
who you are what you stand for and start
making decisions around that makes a
huge difference in your self-confidence
because when you're saying no to
something it's out of conviction not out
of fear being judged and coming in at
number five is don't seek the acceptance
of others with Ralph smart I get over a
thousand questions every single day from
people who have a low self-esteem
a lot of the models actors people who
you might consider to be extroverts
right I've even had a low self-esteem
for a little while and this can affect
any single person on planet earth right
let me share with you what's helped me
along my journey it starts with this are
you someone who allows other people to
give you value self-esteem we're talking
about how you see yourself how you value
yourself right so once I stopped letting
other people give me a self evaluation a
low self-esteem was never an issue again
are you always at the mercy of other
people goodness gracious
it must be a nightmare that is one of
the biggest catalysts for your low
self-esteem so stop having what I call
unconditional positive self-acceptance
what say it again Ralph unconditional
positive self-acceptance
you see most of us in society we don't
accept ourselves we wait for other
people to accept us before we actually
say okay well I'm good enough no you
were good enough
way before I told you you were good
enough you were good enough way before
that person told you you were good
enough or the cat down the road for that
matter okay so how do we even begin to
accept ourselves right that is the issue
well it comes when you stop comparing
yourself to other people when you start
appreciating what you have when you
start seeing what is going right in your
life as opposed to what is falling apart
right my life's not perfect but even
that bird is telling me Ralph you got a
roof over your head you woke up alive
today life is pretty good
thank you guys so much for watching I
hope you enjoyed I'd love to know which
of the clips resonated the most with you
what's the lesson you're gonna take from
this video that applies just the most
heavily to you you're gonna make some
kind of instant action in your life
because of watching this video
what is that leave in the comments below
I'm also curious how do you boost your
self-esteem is there an extra bonus tip
that you want to share with my audience
and spread a little bit more love to
believe nation leave it down in the
comments below finally I want to give a
quick shout out to ball deep Barack
thank you so much man for picking up a
copy of my new book the top ten was a
success and posting it with your awesome
picture on Twitter I really appreciate
it man thank you so much for the support
and I hope you enjoy the read so thank
you guys again for watching I believe in
you I hope we continue to believe in
yourself and whatever your one where it
is much love I'll see you soon
so many times we we we validate who we
are by what we're doing for other people
you know we who we are is what we do
what we give how we love and what I'm
very clear on is that you are giving the
world an example of how they get to love
you and treat you based on the way you
love and treat yourself loving myself
more
looks like giving myself a chance giving
yourself a chance giving yourself a
chance at that thing you've been
thinking about it don't nobody else know
about that you're wondering if it'll
work it's giving yourself a chance to
fly even at the chance that you might
fall and if you fall loving yourself is
getting back up you might not spring up
you might I've wobbled up a few times I
didn't spring that I got up slow I got
the air knocked out of me my heart was
hurting my elbow were bruised but it
wasn't about getting up fast it was
about just getting back up loving
yourself is being willing to do that and
to do it first for you before you do it
for anyone else if you can cheer me for
yourself the way you cheer leave for
them mmm and you can dance and show up
for yourself the way you show up for
them you already know what loving heart
looks like just do all that to you and
see what that looks like
took me a long time to get there
I'm not speaking to something that I
arrived at I couldn't Google download
self-love you can't Google download
self-love you gotta you gotta try it on
you got to stop and breathe you got to
listen to your internal GPS system more
than you listening to chatter and you
listening to Facebook you gotta listen
to what's in your soul and then you
gotta hear it and listen and be an
action like you heard and when you fall
get up to fall again another day
what apply it you know a second way to
build your self-esteem is to set goals
is to say if I could achieve anything at
all in life what would I like to achieve
in the weeks and months and years ahead
and write it down write it down write it
down here's what psychologists have
discovered setting big goals for
yourself improves your self-image and
raises your self-esteem you actually
like yourself and respect yourself more
when you have big goals for your life
you have more self-confidence and you're
happier about yourself
too often we base our value on how
someone is treating us how successful we
are how perfect of a life we've lived
the problem is all of those things can
change if you're getting your value out
of how people treat you then if they
hurt you they disappoint you you're
going to feel devalued if you're basing
your value off of your achievements how
much you make what you drive the title
behind your name then if something
happens and you don't have that position
your business goes down then your value
will go down and some people don't feel
good about themselves because they've
made mistakes in life they're not where
they thought they would be now they're
living insecure feeling inferior their
Bay
seeing their value on their performance
how someone treats you doesn't change
your value what they say or do doesn't
lessen who you are mistakes you've made
doesn't decrease your value that's what
you did that's not who you are
you can buy a bigger house drive a
better car but that doesn't make you any
more valuable that increases your net
worth not your self-worth
you are already valuable when you had
the small apartment and no title behind
your name that position may give you
more influence but not more value you
can be a stay-at-home mom raising your
children you may not have the influence
of the CEO but you have the same value
value is not based on what you do what
you make who you know that's superficial
those things can change the enemy works
overtime trying to devalue us he'd love
for you to go through life letting what
people say make you feel inferior
comparing your life to somebody else's
thinking you'll feel good about yourself
when you catch up to them when you live
in that neighborhood or when you perform
perfectly when you break the addiction
then you'll feel valuable but nothing
you do will make you any more valuable
nothing you achieve nothing you overcome
you are valuable right now God calls you
a masterpiece
you are one-of-a-kind you didn't come
off an assembly line you aren't
mass-produced God made you unique there
will never be another you put your
shoulders back start carrying yourself
with confidence you have been fearfully
and wonderfully made raise your standard
Apple at the core is core values
is that we believe that people your
passion can change the way people not
one drop of myself work depends on
Europe it's supposed to mean I don't
ever give up I'd have to be dead or
absolutely infested
hey believe nation if you want to see my
all-time favorite top ten most a success
I have a very special secret video for
you these are the individual clips that
I have personally learned the most from
and applied to my life and my business
check the link in description for
details